we have some stunning new polling
numbers which should
serve to do nothing and uh other than to
reinforce
the opportunity that we have to remove
donald trump in november
if we all get out and vote this is a
stunning new poll out of north carolina
which puts
joe biden seven points ahead of donald
trump
this is not a democratic-leaning poll in
fact it gives biden a bigger advantage
over trump
than two recent left-leaning polls from
change research and ppp which
respectively have biden
plus one and plus four this poll of
registered voters
says biden is winning by seven and as we
approach election day
i've said before we will see a
transition from registered voter
models being used in polling to likely
voter models
and what's interesting is that the
admittedly democratic
leaning change research poll is a likely
voter model and may actually be more
accurate than joe biden's lead in north
carolina if indeed it exists
may be significantly smaller than the
seven points
that we have most recently seen on
average joe biden's lead in north
carolina
is now three now as a reminder in 2016
donald trump
won north carolina by a little more than
three and a half points and
certainly losing north carolina would be
a really bad signal for donald trump
and one that you know depending on the
numbers we might know about relatively
early on november 3rd
north carolina being on the east coast
voting closes earlier
than a lot of other states and if it's
not even close in north carolina we
might know that
very early in the evening and that would
be an important signal about the way the
election is going to go
now just as important out of north
carolina based on what we were talking
about
yesterday the democratic senate
candidate cal cunningham has a
nine point lead in the same poll over
the incumbent republican senator tom
tillis
this would be a huge victory this would
be tremendous in the context of
democrats maybe taking the senate as we
were discussing yesterday
so now it's time for a word of caution
that is different than my warning from
earlier about everybody has to vote and
trump can win that was a general sort of
word of caution
now i want to be a little more specific
we see joe biden winning on average by
almost eight points in florida
six in wisconsin eight in michigan seven
in pennsylvania
four in arizona this should remind us
that we can't
underestimate donald trump remember that
in 2018
a record number of republicans voted in
the midterms
and because democrats also had record
turnout we picked up a bunch of seats in
the house
so if democrats in 2020
and left-leaning independents merely
match
prior turnout we could easily lose
so as we see these numbers as important
as they are as
signals about an opportunity to not only
defeat donald trump and maybe take the
senate and grow the majority in the
house
we should be reminded that when
republicans see this polling
they may become more vote motivated to
vote some may
write these polls off as fake polls but
not all of them
meaning we need to not just match
but exceed our biggest ever turnout and
i believe we need to dramatically exceed
it
as we approach november if the
administration
is indeed lying about coronavirus
numbers if
you see successful efforts to restrict
absentee voting by mail
close polling places federal
paramilitary troops
intimidating voters like if you add all
of this stuff up a little bit a little
bit a little bit death of a thousand
cuts
we need not just to exceed prior turnout
but we need to dramatically exceed prior
turnout in order to not
allow this to be a missed opportunity
maybe trump won't get out the vote
great we benefit okay maybe trump won't
be able to suppress the vote because
judges or
who knows will prevent fantastic
whatever we can't control that
and so what we can do is vote ourselves
and get out the vote and make sure that
we are so
overwhelming turnout that the dirty
tricks can't work
there will be dirty tricks we're already
seeing them
there's no question that there will be
dirty tricks the question is
will they matter because if we really
boost turnout in a way that
typically nobody does everybody talks
about boosting turnout and rarely does
it does it really happen
to the degree that i'm thinking about
and many people are thinking about only
if we do that
can we say the dirty tricks won't work
the dirty tricks won't be
enough and that's exactly what we need
to hope for now in the meantime donald
trump
i don't know if this is a good strategy
i'll talk about it
donald trump is just insisting the polls
are fake and that may actually be
a counterproductive strategy for him i'm
going to talk about that next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video